welcome to the Matt Walsh show hello
thanks for being here and I remind you
to subscribe if you want to get the
whole show subscribe on iTunes or become
a premium member of The Daily wire it's
interesting I think to get a look at the
makings of an anti-christian media hit
piece to be able to see it you know to
be able to see the sausage being made
and that's the opportunity that was
given to us by a reporter from the New
York Times helpfully enough Dan Levin of
the New York Times sent out of tweets
yesterday and the tweet said this I'm a
New York Times reporter writing about
hashtag exposed Christian schools are
you in your 20s or younger who went to a
Christian school I'd like to hear about
your experience and its impact on your
life please DM me and of course the
exposed Christian school hashtag is just
an anti Christian hashtag where people
are complaining about their Christian
school experiences so Dan has set out to
write a negative story about Christian
schools and and what he's basically
saying here is is hey folks looking to
paint Christian schools in a negative
light do you have any ammo come on give
me some ammo this is what I need which
of course I'm not surprised to see a New
York Times reporter operating that way
but I am kind of surprised to see him do
it so openly and publicly now that that
hashtag exposed Christian schools it
basically consists of two things mainly
it's a bunch of people as I said just
generally mocking Christian schools
accusing them of providing a subpar
education especially in the realm of
science also there are people on a more
serious note talking about their the
bullying they say they they endured or
in some cases even alleged sexual abuse
that they say they experienced in
Christian private schools now I don't
doubt that some of these stories are
true
and maybe most of them I don't know but
the problem is the broad picture that
people are painting of Christian schools
as a place that's hostile to learning a
place that is emotionally intellectually
even
physically unsafe to be I mean if you go
and you read those tweets you get this
impression of Christian school as just
this horrific hellish nightmare place
that why would anyone ever spend money
to send their kids there the kind of
place that you would pay money to to to
avoid going to you pay money for the
privilege of not having to send your
kids or that that's the way that it's
painted now in order to illustrate why
this broad brush approach is unfair and
misleading and disingenuous I thought
you know maybe we should just examine
how incredibly it easy it would be to do
the exact same thing with public schools
and I could argue that a hashtag exposed
public school campaign would be a far
more important and worthy and critical
endeavor considering the vast majority
of kids go to public school and the vast
majority of people in our society went
to public school so that we we live in a
culture Society largely shaped by public
schools so that if there are big
problems in public schools that becomes
a problem for everybody not just people
who went to those schools so if we were
to do a hashtag exposed public schools
what might we say well in terms of
sexual abuse
it is absolutely rampant in public
schools there was a study commissioned
by the Department of Education
several years ago which found that one
in ten public school students are
targets of sexual misconduct by teachers
now that works out to over four million
victims and out of that number three
million have experienced allegedly
actual sexual assault this me
that the epidemic of sexual abuse in our
public school system is 100 times worse
than the sex scandal in the Catholic
Church though it has probably gotten 100
times less attention when are we gonna
get the the you know news article
exposed public schools talking about
this and nobody cares about this in fact
I wrote an article about this issue I
I've talked about this many times the
sex abuse epidemic in the public school
system because she would think it'd be
something we care about considering
again the vast majority of us say I
don't but the vast majority of people
send their kids public school you would
think that when you hear four million
victims of sex and sexual misconduct by
teachers in public school you would
think that we would all say oh well
that's a problem we should be talking
about right but nobody wants to talk
about it and the reason they don't want
to talk about it is because they send
their kids in public school and so they
don't want to have to confront this or
deal with it because just it's it's
easier not to which I would say is of
course the height of cowardice I wrote
an article several months ago and the
title was something like the public
school system is crawling with sex
predators but nobody cares that was the
title of my article and it's true that
nobody cared I mean that article I think
that like I don't know ten thousand
reads or something like that in the
first couple of days which is very very
low which yeah okay it's not about they
the hits to the article it's just about
this should be something we care about
but it but it's it's clear even at that
in there I've written about at other
times too
every time written by this issue it just
nobody wants to read about it nobody
wants to hear about it
and this is only abuse by teachers by
the way abuse by students on other
students is also a crisis in the public
school system recently the AP put out a
report and they found seventeen thousand
cases of student on student abuse in a
four year period and these are just the
cases that are reported so if you got
seven
thousand reported cases of student on
student sexual abuse in a four year
period think about all that how many are
not reported you have to multiply that
by what three four five when you factor
in all the unreported instances what
about bullying
okay there's there was a lot of talk in
the expose Christian school hashtag
about bullying in Christian schools well
we're told all the time that there's a
bullying crisis in the schools generally
is that all from the Christian schools
no of course not many kids in public
school face daily torment I went to
public school myself for twelve years
I'm not going to say that I faced daily
bullying and torment but I saw it myself
I was I was in that environment with
everyone else and like anyone else who
went to public school for all that time
I saw these things myself happening this
this outright viciousness this sort of
emotional chaos this Lord of the fly is
like social environment in the public
school system the way that kids are
alienated mocked excluded suicide is an
increasingly common phenomenon among
children even very young children and
and many of those cases are connected to
bullying it seems like every case almost
every case that I've read has been in
some way connected to the bullying now
you might say well it's not fair to pin
all of that on public schools yes
exactly that's my point
so why are we pinning it on Christian
schools what's the point of a campaign a
look at all these terrible things
happening in Christian schools when I
could do the exact same thing with
public schools and that's where almost
everyone goes to school and then there's
the quality of the education itself well
again this is not really a conversation
that works out well for public schools
and let's start with the fact that for
the fifth time most people in this
country have been public schools so all
you have to do is look around you okay
we don't even need to pull out studies
and surveys and this
that test results okay just look around
you at society does it appear to you
that most people in our society are
well-educated intelligent well-read
critical thinkers is is that is that the
sort of society that you imagine we live
in no I don't think so
we all know that stupidity and
intellectual laziness is endemic in our
culture you know nobody reads anymore no
one thinks for themselves we we frankly
live in a culture filled with idiots for
lack of a better or nicer way of putting
it and where did most of those idiots go
to school private or public what do we
think it's just this is just a matter of
percentages here what about anti science
indoctrination at public school these
days you will learn that girls can have
penises okay so you want to talk about
anti science that says anti science as
it gets you'll learn that gender is not
biological again as anti science as you
can possibly get and if we're offering
anta antic the anecdotes that's the word
I'm looking for although I'd like to
have an antidote too but if we're
offering anecdotes look at me I went to
public school I don't even know the
difference difference we can't antidote
in an anecdote so you know I'm Exhibit A
here but if we are talking about
personal stories I can tell you about
some of the utter nonsense that my
science teachers taught me in public
school like I was taught that
deforestation was going to deplete the
world's oxygen supply within a few years
I was taught or at least given the
strong impression that if you're in the
same room as somebody smoking for even
like 10 minutes you could get lung
cancer I was taught about I was taught
the myth of overpopulation only oh I was
I wasn't told that it was a myth by the
way this was all in elementary school
where I was where all of these paranoid
delusions were being foist upon me and
terrifying me and all my classmates well
we were given this impression of the
world that was on the brink of collapse
and you know if you even go near someone
who's smoking you'll be you'll die of
cancer within days this is the the
impression that we were being given and
then there's also just random dumb stuff
like I remember my middle school science
teacher taught us that blood is blue
when it's inside your body which which
which is not by the way just because it
looks blue in your veins doesn't mean
that actually is blue but and I know
that that's a common misconception that
people have well number one it's fight
it's a common misconception but it
should be common misconception that a
person who teaches science for a living
has and why is that a common
misconceptions why are they so common
have you thought about that is because
this is what people are being taught in
schools I saw plenty of educational
incompetence I had a geography teacher
who didn't know that Georgia is a
country which fine you know if I just
run into someone on the street who
doesn't know about about Georgia as a
country you know maybe I won't pass too
harsh judgments on them but if you teach
geography at school you should know
about the existence I mean you you
should know about the existence of
pretty much every country this is what
you teach I mean am I crazy or like
shouldn't you have every country
memorized and if this is what you teach
is what you do
should you at the very least know
whatever every country that exists I had
several teachers who taught I had
several Spanish teachers who did not
appear to actually know Spanish I had
one who would put a hoe put on Selena
the movie Selena with Jennifer Lopez we
watched that all the way through like
four times because I don't think she
actually knew the language and so we
just sat there and watched Jennifer
Lopez films and that's a very that's a
time-honored tradition in public schools
is just watching movies that are you
know at best loosely connected to the
subject but have no educational value
whatsoever with a teacher and and keep
in mind we're talking about forty-five
minute periods so if the teacher says
you know we're gonna watch a
two-and-a-half-hour movie that means
it's almost an entire week of class is
going to be spent watching this movie
so I had plenty of teachers like that I
had teachers who taught class by just
handing out a worksheet and then sitting
silently at their desk and doing
whatever they were doing I had teachers
who taught I had teachers who never
taught I had teachers sat in their class
for a year they never taught a class
ever never taught what they would do is
they would read from the textbook they
would hand out did us that's it that's
all they would and they would assign
tests there was never any teaching no
lecturing no explaining none I had
plenty of teachers like that
what about ideological indoctrination
well I experienced that at every level
of public school just as as most public
school students do um in every grade in
many classes open hostility to
conservative and Christian beliefs was
utterly commonplace totally expected and
accepted so why aren't we exposing
public school oh because it's somehow
suddenly unfair to paint with this broad
brush when it comes to publics when it
comes to government education suddenly
it's no no we can't do that funny how
that works all right Owen Schroyer is a
reporter with Infowars and he was
sexually assaulted by a demonstrator at
the Women's March over the weekend the
the crime occurred on camera and the
woman who did it openly admitted to it
in fact here's the just just watch this
here's the video is that sexual assault
yes
so you just sexually assaulted you be
arrested arrest me I'm not gonna arrest
you they're police officers right here
but so look at this women have so much
privilege she can sexually assault me
and get away with it if I did that to
her I'd get arrested now okay
put aside however you may feel about
Infowars because that doesn't make a
difference here that should make any
difference the fact remains the same a
woman walked over to Schroyer groped his
genitals
announced that she had quote grabbed him
and and then and then proudly said yes
when she was asked is that sexual
assault she said yes and then she dumped
then and then she just to make it even
more clear she says I assaulted you it
was assault so she does it on camera
admits to it brags about it people
surrounding her just applaud there our
police officer standing right there
there are police officers just standing
there like hmm okay
and in this video makes it online and
there's no outrage there is no reaction
nobody cares
now I don't need to point out the
obvious but I'm going to anyway that if
the roles were reversed here let's let's
just imagine that it was let's imagine
that it was the March for Life now this
wouldn't never happen in the March for
Life but let's imagine was the March for
Life and and there was a liberal
reporter from or you know whoever from
salon or I don't know Jezebel or
something I don't even know if Jezebel
has reporters but there was some liberal
reporter there you know reporting on the
march of life and then a male pro-lifer
walked over on camera and to make a
point or to express his political
frustration with the woman he grabbed
her by the by the genitals and then
laughed about it and then said yes I
assaulted you can you even imagine the
reaction to that video now think about
the reaction that a fifteen-year-old kid
got when he was caught on camera smiling
in the direction of a Native American
now think about the reaction to that
that was a that was a week-long outrage
cycle it was their death threats bomb
scares he had to shut the school down
because a kid smiled
there were think pieces raining from the
sky and people talking about oh the
miele and people writing hold you know
tweet threads and tweet storms about
about the the problem with white people
smiling and that was just for a smile
can you imagine if a guy did that his
life would be over number one which i
mean they would be he'd be a total
scumbag for doing it so he would of
course deserve consequences and it
wouldn't just be social consequences he
would also be arrested that's the other
thing there's just no chance that a guy
could do that to a woman with a cop
standing right there without the cop
intervening so yet the reverse happens
and it's just everyone goes hmm
okay in fact worse than that the people
surrounding her seem to get a kick out
of it so not only is this woman not
facing consequences but if anything
there are probably positive consequences
for her she probably has just upped her
her her feminist street cred now you
just can't you just can't claim that you
care about sexual assault you care about
things like consent if you're gonna see
a video like that and shrug it off that
is sexual assault according to every
definition that I have heard that is
100% sexual assault and if we're if
everything is equal and if everything is
fair and everything's the same then we
have to agree that that is just as bad
as if a man had done it is exactly the
same thing so the outrage should be
exactly the same but it's not because as
I have said many times including
recently the me2 movement was completely
fraudulent it was ideological from the
start and you know most of these the
feminists and everything shouting about
the meanto movement this it was all it
was all really
politics it was convenient to use this
issue for political ends but it was
never really about stopping sexual
assault because if it was then things
like this would be plastered everywhere
and everyone we talking about it and by
the way also if the me to movement was
really about sexual assault then as part
of the me to crusade we would have also
been having a conversation about all
these female public school teachers who
are sleeping with their who are excuse
me sexually assaulting their male
students all the time we would have any
conversation about that in fact what I
just did there you can see how even I
can be programmed by the media sometimes
and I have to I have to kind of a catch
myself Midway because the way that the
media reports when a when a oftentimes
when a female public school teacher
sexually assault a male student the way
that they reported that they'll say
something like I've seen headlines like
a female teacher caught in sex romp with
high school boy you know things like or
sleeping with like the phrase that I use
when really no no no it's not a sex Rob
it's not sleeping with it's not caught
in a relationship with it is sexually
assaulting but we are so programmed to
just see that as something completely
different and even maybe okay when it's
not alright the family of
sixteen-year-old Covington Catholic
student Nicholas salmon speaking of him
has hired a high-powered lawyer who's
special special eise's in going after
media organizations for libel and
slander and I think this is great this
is this is the kind of fighting back
that needs to happen and it's usually
difficult to win libel or defamation
suits for many reasons and I'm no lawyer
so I'm not gonna try to get into the
specific specifics of it but as I
understand it difficult to win for a few
reasons number one you have to prove
that the person engaging in this
defamation or the libel
knew that what they're saying was untrue
about you and that they were saying it
for they were trying to hurt you by
saying it and then you also have to
prove that you have been hurt by
whatever thing was said about you that
has caused that has damaged you in some
way and those two things can can be
difficult to prove but in this case I
think would be enormous both things
would be enormous ly easy to prove
you know these various so-called
journalists and media outlets and famous
people who were spreading videos that
they knew were out of context and that
we're continuing to push the narrative
even after the full context came into
view and that obviously had malicious
intent in doing so and some of them were
openly saying let's Docs this kid or
let's let's go after school let's find
out about this kid in some there were
people openly encouraging others to
harass or worse these kids these
children so I think they have a very
good case to make and although I
normally would not wish unemployment or
financial ruination on people in this
case the people who who slandered and
defame these kids I do hope that they
are sued into bankruptcy and that they
lose their jobs and that they suffer
severe consequences because of it
professional and financial consequences
because that's justice number one and
number two this is the only way that
we're going to stop these things for
happening in the future all right one
other quickly mention before I get to
some of your emails credit where it's
due I was complaining yesterday about
the lack of leadership among Catholic
Bishops especially in general in this
country but especially after that New
York law abortion law was passed and the
what I thought was pretty weak statement
from the Catholic Bishops in New York
who expressed sadness about it and said
that it was terrible they were
heartbroken which is fine iii-it's I
agree it's sad and I'm also heartbroken
but there's got to be there
you have to be angry there has to be
fire in brimstone calling down God's
judgment on these people that that's the
kind of reaction that you should have
and then there should also be
excommunication so it's not just
verbally reacting or issuing
condemnation but actually doing
something about it
a few bishops they'll have stepped up
Bishop Rick steiker
from in Tennessee I believe said tweeted
this days and someone asked me today if
I would issue an excommunication of a
Catholic governor under my jurisdiction
if the governor did the same as in New
York I think I might do it for any
Catholic legislator under my
jurisdiction who voted for the bill as
well as the governor enough is enough he
continues excommunication is to be a
punishment is to be not a punishment to
but to bring the person back into the
church it's like medicine for them but
this vote is so hideous and vile that it
warrants the act but thankfully I am NOT
in that position very sad then Bishop
Strickland of Tyler Texas says the video
of the celebration of New York
legislators as they condemned even
full-term unborn children to death by
choice is a scene from hell
woe to those who ignore the sanctity of
life they reap the whirlwind of hell
stand against this Holocaust in every
way you can okay amen exactly that's the
reaction that that's what that's what we
need to see from from leaders of the
church from Christians generally is not
just oh that's tragic that's unfortunate
but but actual anger we need to see that
you're mad about it that you're
righteously anger angry about what's
happening to these to these children
finally let's get to some of your emails
if you want to email the show and have
any comment you want to make question
concern email Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Joe it says I've really
appreciated your shows for a good while
and I particularly appreciate your
articles that are reading a daily wire
few are more clear and straightforward
than you are I'm really interested in
how you describe the parallels between
people today who support abortion and
people in the antebellum South who
supported slavery
you've got away with words that really
sums things up maybe you could
on this point on your show thank you
funny you should ask that Joe there is a
writer who frankly I think is not
terribly talented and I personally find
to be rather unimpressive in many
respects but he wrote a book called the
unholy trinity by Matt Walsh and this
book available on on Amazon by the way
in this book he and I mean I of course
deal with this question exactly so let
me it seems kind of self-indulgent abut
I did I did I kind of laid it out here
in the book so the the parallels between
the arguments for slavery and the
arguments for abortion are I think that
they are pretty much exact parallels so
there is an appeal to privacy where we
say who are you to tell someone what to
do with their own property / body
there's an appeal to the superseding
right my property / body rights come
before the rights of a slave / fetus
there's appeal and appeal to
inevitability slavery / abortion has
been going on front going on for
thousands of years and it's never gonna
go away we might as well have a safe and
legal system in place for it there's an
appeal to pseudoscience slave / fetuses
aren't really people they aren't like us
look at them they're physically
different therefore we are human and
they are not there's the appeal to
socioeconomic concerns if slavery /
abortion ends most of these slaves /
babies will end up on the street without
a job appeal to the courts slavery /
abortion was vindicated by the Supreme
Court it's already been decided there's
no point arguing about it the appeal to
folk impression slavery / abortion is in
the best interests of African / babies
the world can be a cruel place it's best
to protect them from it by keeping them
enslaved / killing them appeal to the
Bible slavery / abortion isn't
specifically condemned in the Bible if
it's if it's wrong Jesus would have
specifically said so so those are a
number of parallel arguments that there
are others - that you could probably
think of but when you look at and you
look at the ways that slavery was
actually justified at the time you're
going to find that yes it is it really
is like a mad lib you could just take
out every where it says slavery and plug
in abortion and it would
often still the sentence would still
work and make sense and that's that's an
interesting thing by the way because
it's easy for us now when we look at
something like slavery and we say well
that's just an evil terrible thing and
you know so we just see it we look back
on slavery as this sort of historical
phenomenon even though it's still
happening other parts of the world but
in our country we look back on a
historical phenomenon and we say well
that was that terrible thing that
happened in the past and that's all and
of course it was a terrible an evil
thing but we forget that plenty of
actual people who would have seemed like
normal people at the time and would have
probably considered themselves to be
decent people supported slavery or had
slaves and so they would have had
arguments to defend like actual
arguments there was a time course not
this way anymore but there was a time
when this was a live argument where
there were two sides of it and you
people would shout at each other and
argue and debate it just like they do
now so it's important to remember that
and then go back and look at the
arguments not because the arguments are
good
no but because of course not but because
what you'll find if you if you if you go
back and you look at history within its
context you'll find that evil
dehumanizing despicable murderous things
are always justified and argued for in
the same way so there's these these same
arguments and justifications that just
come up again and again throughout human
history to justify the latest evil
institution that every one happens to
find convenient and so wants to find a
way to justify it's just the same
argument I keep coming up and we don't
notice it because we don't have this
this we don't have a contextual view of
history we don't actually go back and
look at it and put ourselves into that
environment again and look at it from
that perspective because if we did that
we would see that oh look
history really does repeat itself and
all the cliches about if you don't learn
from history you're doomed to repeat it
I mean all these cliches they actually
are
completely true Jenna says hi Matt I
appreciate your logical approach to
breaking down the arguments for abortion
recently you talked about four arguments
for abortion and I was wondering if you
could address a fifth one I was talking
about the four arguments that people
always use for abortion which of course
are bad arguments what would you say to
someone who makes the argument for
abortion in cases where the baby's
health is very poor in his life which
may be very short would be filled with
complicated medical procedures limited
cognitive functioning pain etc this is
something I've heard from heartbroke and
women who say keeping the baby would be
selfish what's your logical rebuttal and
how would you talk about it with women
and families who've had an abortion for
this reason
thanks for question Jenna you know I
think looking at this objectively the
the there's not much difficulty for me
looking at it and look I understand if
you in the situation you're in the
position you've got all the emotions
tugging you and sever but but looking at
it objectively it's clear that it makes
no sense to kill a baby because you're
afraid that the baby's gonna die anyway
makes no sense to do that just because a
baby is going to die doesn't mean that
you ought to just kill it just because a
life is going to be short doesn't mean
that it's worthless and so I think we
see in this attitude a very utilitarian
kind of superficial view of life where
we say well if you don't have X amount
of days if you're not gonna get how many
days I don't know but if you're not
gonna get a certain amount of days or
certain at that time well then there's
no point of life but if we see life as
eternally precious and valuable then we
see that one minute of life is is
something that ought to be protected at
all costs
two minutes an hour two days because
it's life and you only get you're only
gonna get one I mean a child every human
we only get the one mortal existence
and so it is the most valuable thing in
the world no matter how short it's going
to be so if a child's gonna have a very
short life that's incredibly sad but
then why not give them that life at
least and also the chance maybe at a
longer life
maybe there's a miracle maybe there's a
medical breakthrough I mean it's
extremely unlikely in many cases but
there's always a chance you hear about
these cases and even if there's no
chance again well then that's then
that's all the life the child is going
to get so let them have that life and if
we say well it'll be a miserable
existence pain-filled that's not that's
not up to us to decide we don't get to
make that determination for other people
that well that life might not be must
not be worthwhile because there's pain
and they're suffering because obviously
it's easy to see the slippery slope
there if we are standing here and making
those determinations for other people
and saying that well if you're severely
disabled or if you're impaired in some
way there's no point of life and so
we're gonna kill babies for that well
then it's obvious to see what it's going
to start happening on the other end of
life too and it does happen in some
countries that way it's a terrible thing
so life is a normal suit part every
moment of life is enormous ly eternally
precious and so we should be allowed to
live every moment of life that God has
given us and and also we cannot decide
for other people even for our children
that their life is not worth living and
just to kind of flesh this out a little
bit think about you know let's think of
a kind of sci-fi hypothetical let's say
it's it's in the future and it's sort of
a Minority Report situation where or
it's like the movie Gattaca or one of
the one of these dystopian futuristic
movies where you can actually do some
kind of genetic test and find out
exactly when your child is going to die
and of what let's just say let's just
say that that was possible well what if
you find out that your child is going to
live a healthy life for three years but
then get leukemia in the fourth year and
die when he's five what if you find out
that
your child's gonna get hit by a car when
he's 8 years old what if you find out
that your child's going to you know die
of some other illness when he's 12 or 13
I mean would would you just get an
abortion then I mean would we just say
well there's no point if you're only
going to live for four years you only
gonna live for eight you're only going
to live for 12 there's no point of
living so we see it we see what happens
here we see the problem
at what point how many years do you need
to get under your belt before we would
say well that's that right there is the
worthwhile life it just becomes absurd
when you think of it that way and we see
how that is just not a determination
that we can make or should try to make
Joe I think well I just read from a Joe
that's a different show I think says hi
Matt besides your own father could you
speak a little bit about your about
other father figures who have inspired
you along your journey Joe well for
leaving out my earthly father and I
assume you also mean aside from my
Heavenly Father then I'm left with just
the great men that I've read about and
read from who've been hugely influential
for me so I don't know if they count as
father figures but huge influences CS
Lewis Solzhenitsyn John Henry Newman and
of course Batman as well from Alex he
says Matt why do you feel the need to
give your opinion on every single
subject that's what I've noticed about
you especially as I follow you on
twitter you chime in on every kind of
subject as if you're an expert it gets
old after a while I'm just wondering why
do you feel the need it's a medical
condition Alex it's called loud mouth
itis and I would appreciate it and all
the members of the loud mouth community
would who who deal with enough bullying
and discrimination and harassment as it
is we would appreciate it if you would
stop your bigotry from Mike Matt what is
your least what is your least favorite
amendment in the Bill of Rights okay
what is your least favorite amendment
the Bill of Rights you know what when I
first saw this email I mind I read that
as what is your favorite amendment in
the Bill of Rights and so I bookmarked
it to answer on the show and I'm only
now noticing that it's actually your
least favorite amendment the Bill of
Rights which is a much more interesting
question and I would say that you know
what Mike I am tempted to say I am
tempted to side with the Federalists and
say that that all of them are my least
favorite it may
maybe they should all be repealed not
because I disagree with the rights
themselves obviously but I have you know
increasingly I have felt that maybe it
was it really was a mistake to write the
Bill of Rights because the whole idea
originally what the Constitution is okay
we're going to enumerate the powers of
the government and then that's all they
can do and if it's not in there they
can't do it so there's no reason to get
specific and say you know you have a
right to free speech you have a right to
guns well that's already implied because
the government was not given the power
in the Constitution to restrict free
speech or to restrict your gun rights so
you don't need to start laying all that
out the approach to the Constitution
should be or should have been arguably
that here's what the government can do
if it's not in there they can't do it
and so everything else
those are your rights there's there
aren't only ten of them there are
hundreds thousands really maybe millions
of things that you can do that the
government can't stop you from doing or
has no role in because it's not in there
so what happened though with the Bill of
Rights is that things have been kind of
flipped around and the Bill of Rights
has arguably been used ironically to
limit rights rather than to protect them
because the attitude now is well if it's
not in there then you don't have that
right I mean these are your rights as a
human and if you if it's not there then
that means the government can do it so
you see how it's been exactly reversed
it was supposed to be if it's not in
there the government can do it now it's
if it's not in there the Bill of Rights
then you can't do it so it has become
limiting and also when you start trying
to enumerate human rights it becomes
very problematic because there are way
too many to list and and they are such
sort of broad kind of concepts that you
can start smuggling in other things that
don't belong there which we've seen the
Supreme Court do especially in the 20th
20th century so the the Supreme Court
could look at the amendments and say oh
well look at that there's a right to
abortion in there you know hey what do
you know actually there's a right to
abortion which is based on the right to
privacy a right to
abortion which is not in the
Constitution based on a right to privacy
which is also not in the Constitution so
these are the games that the Supreme
Court was able to play because of the
Bill of Rights so maybe it never should
have been written in the first place but
it was finally Jesse hi mr. Walsh I was
interested to find out that you're a
football fan I had well I was but I've
retired from being a football fan I just
watched bass fishing now because as a
Ravens fan I cannot deal with the
heartbreak any longer so I've given up
at least until the next season starts I
have a question for you that you might
not want to bother answering on the show
but I'm interested to hear if you did
the NFL seems to make changes to its
rules every year in the offseason what
rule changes would you recommend if it
were up to you well I would recommend
first of all that they stop making real
changes every offseason I would also
recommend that they just take their
rulebook which is longer than the Bible
at that at this point and just how about
just randomly tear out half of the pages
and just get rid of all some of the
goods they're way too many rules
but here's one rule just to actually
answer your question here's one rule
change I believe that it should finally
be allowed that coaches can challenge
penalties because as you know right now
in the NFL you cannot challenge a
penalty I think coaches should get three
challenges in a game and they can
challenge anything they want they could
challenge a call on the field they could
challenge a play they can also challenge
a penalty because penalty calls
erroneous penalty calls have such a
profound impact on the game and can
change the outcome of a game something
like a pass interference call an
erroneous pass interference call can
completely change the outcome of game
can give the game to a team that
shouldn't have won this kind of stuff
happens all the time and so obviously we
should have the ability to stop and go
back and and take that back you know if
a ref calls pass interference then you
look at the replay and the guy didn't
even touch him well as it goes now we
have to say well okay we just got to go
with it I guess that team's gonna win
now cuz they got it ends up being a 30
yard penalty two minutes left in the
game and they say score a touchdown when
otherwise it would have been fourth and
20 and now they win the game now we have
to say well it's just how it is when it
would be really easy to just go back and
look at it and say oh never mind that
really wasn't a pass interference
there's no reason why we'd have to stick
with that just because you threw the
flag so that's a real rule change that I
would that I would make all right we'll
leave it there have a great weekend
everybody
Godspeed